you've asked you so we started out its
show with with Henry care he's a skier
as you know yes and and III thought of
you because I wondered your profession
how physical is that I mean do you do
you have to do exercise to be able to
play piano like this I mean more on the
hand but certainly when you're playing
like every second day it need to you
move it's a lot of physical power and so
I do a little bit exercise ping-pong
yeah yeah so what you do is amazing and
I think I cannot fly like that but I
think the better physical condition that
we have is the better of course do you
do you have like do you get paints like
he does which part I like all over the
place all over the place maybe not the
fingers in the hands but every other
part Wow see that's the sacrifice yeah
all right I also have a sometimes pain
you know from the shoulder and I had a
many years ago I had a when they're
called tennis elbow even though I never
played tennis you know but it's hot so
maybe later can call pianists oboe
anyway but you know we need to relax and
to play less I remember in the beginning
when I start I always play big romantic
repertoire like Robin of Tchaikovsky
back to back and my shoulder got really
intense and then I realized mmm I need
to do more Mozart and then you know
somehow better balance well why why did
it become the piano for you I mean you
started out so young why did you choose
that damn instrument for me piano is
loose cooler looks cool yeah I just like
today a lot of young people like guitar
building you know they can be more like
you know
so when did you realize that it looks
cooler how did you how did you realize
that I mean by watching cartoons and I
will speak fan of Tom and Jerry and
Monkey King and do they have pianos
there I mean Tom and Jerry had yes yeah
had a pretty big one you know and I look
at my little piano it looks like the
grandson of the piano but anyway I think
it's a especially the tuxedo you know
and then you can do this thing right but
now I I mean now I don't play with
tuxedo anymore for me is it we're too
long so when when you were like there
that kid with with this cartoonish dream
of being a pianist with a tuxedo did you
I was a typical day in life how was
hours a day then I approached this a lot
and I I was like waking up alarm for my
neighbors so around six o'clock I start
playing so was pretty precise for pretty
precise and one day I was sick I did not
wake up my neighbors
two of my neighbors was late for work
like Henry care you have also had well a
little help from your father to put it
mildly it was quite a pressure wasn't it
yeah I heard you also had a yeah
wonderful very supportive yeah for sure
supportive but old strict as well yeah
so we you know we will become very good
friends yeah because even though you're
still friend with your father and you
even performed with him you he was very
strict and and you you and your father
moved to Beijing to practice more
how's that for you I mean you must have
missed your mother I mean it's yeah that
was the most difficult time
I mean especially at that time yeah
because I never left my mom even for one
day you know it's always my mom's taking
care of me you know and so it was very
strange for the beginning did you have a
piano there yeah
we moved the piano from my hometown yeah
and and then yeah and I had a teacher in
the beginning and the teacher is telling
some really weird technique nobody you
know you sit down the piano you play you
know they'll take a breath and the more
comfortable is better right the sound it
comes better but that teacher told me
this like she has this kind of old
theory from the mountain whatever maybe
she has come from Himalaya or something
so she told me you know the shoulder
needs to be really high so be like a
mountain you know and then and then the
arm need to be like a river you know
coming down you know today you know to
the ocean or whatever so need to play
like that so I felt like I felt like a
polar bear when I was playing and so
that was the technique I learned from
her for half a year and then I totally
played like this and then in the end of
the day she said you're no talent you
should quit your you know you should
quit your piano so yeah she let you go
so I got fired by her yeah I mean how
did your father react to my father but
not totally I mean it was a bad time you
know it was really really you know both
of me and him kind of lost conscious and
then I gave up for playing piano for a
while so you know parent so as you'll
see always like there's one kid and you
have a like a lot of relatives I think
good good job or harder so it's that's
how you know but now I think it's come
come to normal